[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo 26 minutes pour
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
dans le département
au sommaire de cette édition la coupe du
monde du cyclisme sur piste ce week-end
au vélodrome nationale la première
manche de cette coupe du monde se
déroule à saint quentin en yvelines 55
nations plus de 350 pistard reportage à
suivre dans cette édition le modem
sortie de renforcer du remaniement
ministériel
plusieurs changements intervenus ce
mardi au sein du gouvernement pour en
parler nous recevons jean baptiste à
monique il est délégué départemental du
modem des yvelines enfin dans le reste
de l'actualité
nous reviendrons sur la rénovation de la
salle de cinéma le cirano et sur le
forum de l'emploi au centre commercial
espace saint quentin
à suivre aussi dans cette édition notre
nouvelle rubrique ça s'est passé
un voyage dans le temps à travers les
archives de tv 78 mais avant de
développer ces titres le conseil
départemental des yvelines a débloqué
vendredi 19 octobre une subvention de
100 mille euros pour le département de
l'aude une somme attribuée à sept
collectivités frappées par des
inondations en début de semaine première
manche de coupe du monde de cyclisme sur
piste au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
ce week-end plus de 350 athlètes vont
s'affronter sur la piste jeudi soit il
s'était déjà sur leur vélo pour un
dernier entraînement et les premières
qualifications en jeu notamment de ces
épreuves plusieurs tickets pour
participer aux jeux olympiques de tokyo
en 2020 un reportage de patrick jacques
de dixmude et de mes amis poké pesée des
vélos échauffement ce jeudi soir la
coupe du monde de cyclisme a débuté avec
les qualifications de poursuites et de
vitesse par équipes
ça revêt une importance considérable
dans la mesure où les gens viennent
chercher des points pour se qualifier
pour les championnats du monde et c'est
la première épreuve qui est
qualificative pour les jeux olympiques
donc une grande importance pour toutes
les nations présentes ici plus de 350
athlètes sont engagés pour cette
première manche de coupe du monde
parmi les 52 pays représentés de grandes
nations comme les anglais les néo
zélandais et les australiens et la
france on se sent bien l'heure actuelle
et qu'il de france a bien travaillé ces
dernières semaines on a des conditions
ici au niveau du vélodrome
des bonnes conditions climatiques ce
même si si on est sur un vélodrome
couvert c'est important pour nous il
faut savoir que la pression
atmosphérique qui joue beaucoup sur les
performances il fait très chaud
il le bois est très sec à l'heure
actuelle c'est important pour nous de
bien débuter on à domicile donc il faut
qu'on arrive à valider un certain nombre
de résultats pour se mettre dans le
confort les tricolores espère bien
briller sur cette compétition la raison
de championne d'europe de keremma type
de gros 19 ans part favorite sur cette
épreuve et le retour sur ses résultats
de cette compétition dans le 7-8 sports
lundi à partir de 18h30
chaque vendredi dans l'hebdo nous où
vous nous ouvrons les portes des
archives de tv 78 des événements qui ont
fait l'histoire de saint quentin et des
yvelines avec sa ses noces avec notre ça
s'est passé pardon aujourd'hui penchons
nous sur le dossier de l'enfouissement
de la nationale 10 1 s'user un sujet
toujours d'actualité
un reportage préparé par wilfrid richy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les nationalistes en allemand mais très
belles choses à traverser pour les
piétons et j'espère que le projet
d'aménagement concernera un passage
souterrain pour les piétons ce sera
beaucoup moins dangereux pour les
enfants qui habitent de l'autre côté
oui des aménagements pour le passage ça
va
face à station mobile surtout que
dangereux pour les piétons c'est qu'il
faut que je fasse très attention
enfin une déviation
mais passait pas aussi qu'ils ont
construite autour il y a eu deux morts
le week-end des 16 et 17 novembre sur la
nationale 10 attrapés l'encours cela
porte à 18 le nombre de tués en dix ans
sur cette voie pour la seule ville de
trappes depuis 1965 pourtant le
contournement de la ville par
l'autoroute a12 est prévu permettant
ainsi de transformer la nationale 10 en
un boulevard urbain
reste que deux solutions sont
concurrentes l'une inscrite au schéma
directeur d'île de france passerait en
zone urbaine par la verrière et le
mesnil
elle rencontre l'hostilité quasi unanime
des élus locaux
l'autre prenais part ceci passerait plus
au large de la ville nouvelle par le
vallon du pommereux problème il faudrait
des classes et quelques hectomètres de
cette zone boisée au final un blocage
qui dure est contenté de casser des élus
ont sollicité un rendez vous auprès du
préfet illac redit 20 novembre
nous voulions donc dire à monsieur le
préfet que
il ne pouvait pas être accepté en l'état
le tracé médian qui qui est inscrit au
sdrif au schéma de la région
ile-de-france qui se propose de passer
bon dans des conditions que l'on ne
connaît pas encore bien par la proximité
du ministre denis est de en plus ou
moins enterré prod plus ou moins
protégés par la verrière pour déboucher
sur l'a10 vers coignières alors
concernant la nationale 10 nous ne
voulons pas d'aménagement la question
qui est posée c'est la transformation
d'une voix qui aujourd'hui est
autoroutières dans sa configuration qui
donne à l'automobiliste l'impression
qu'ils aient toujours sur l'autoroute de
transformer cette voie ce statut de
voies autoroutières en statue de
boulevard urbain la dde devrait rendre
public dans les six mois une étude sur
les travaux à prévoir sur la nationale
10 à trappes
reste la question du financement des
coûts un dossier qui lui non plus n'est
pas encore ficelé
[Musique]
nous ouvrons une page politique avec
notre invité jean baptiste à monique
bonsoir alors vous êtes délégué
départemental du modem des yvelines le
président la république a engagé un
remaniement de grande ampleur ce mardi
16 octobre huit entrants et quatre
sortants parmi les nouveaux membres du
gouvernement notamment marc fresneau ex
président du groupe modem à l'assemblée
nationale nommé ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement
il remplace christophe castaner désigné
lui ministre de l'intérieur puis
jacqueline gourault proche de françois
bayrou déjà membre du gouvernement qui
prend la tête d'un grand ministère de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
alors ces remaniements il remporte il va
en force vraiment votre parti oui il
renforce le modem
incontestablement mais avant de parler
du modem je pense que là on a un
gouvernement remanié qui a été re dire
que le timing n'était pas forcément
celui qui a été choisi à la base un il
intervient après le départ de gérard
collomb qui a été un peu précipitée mais
on respecte son choix il veut se
consacrer la mairie de lyon c'est tout à
son honneur
non ce remaniement moi la façon dont
donges l'analyse c'est les bonnes
personnes au bon endroit et parmi parmi
ces personnes là y ait des modems il ya
marc fesneau comme vous devez le
signaler qui est président du groupe
modem afin qu'ils étaient président du
groupe modem à l'assemblée qui a réussi
à écrire un vrai collectif et c'est pas
on vois pas ça comme une récompense
disons qu'on voit ça comme la continuité
de l'engagement qu'on a au sein de la
majorité des relations qu'on a pu nouer
avec la république en marche et c'est
vrai qu'on était aussi plusieurs
apprenez peut-être pour un renforcement
de la question territoriale au sein du
programme sein du projet présidentiel et
gouvernemental et le ministère le grand
ministère la cohésion territoriale que
vous évoquez pour jacques une grosse et
forcément une satisfaction pour nous en
plus et récupère les relations avec les
collectivités on sait qu'on en a besoin
aujourd'hui renforcement oui mais
renforcement au service de la majorité
comment vous l'expliquez cette ouverture
vers le modem c'est enfin c'est une
ouverture qui a eu lieu depuis le début
depuis début de puis le moment où
françois bayrou a décidé de soutenir
emmanuel macron au moment de l'élection
présidentielle et on a construit on
achemine est ensemble on a construit on
a construit le projet on a commencé à
réformer le pays ensemble il ya vraiment
ces deux piliers au sein de la majorité
que sont la république en marche et nous
sommes donc c'est pas une ouverture qui
qui voilà qui intervient comme ça du
jour au lendemain après ce qui est vrai
c'est qu'on ait eu un épisode qui a
quand même entre guillemets plaidé en
notre faveur
l'épisode du perchoir où marc fesneau a
décidé de présenter sa candidature non
pas contre richard ferrand mais pour
faire valoir aussi des positions et des
idées qui étaient les nôtres et on vous
avez vu qu'il a doublé le score du
groupe se dire qu'il ya 46 députés au
groupe modem et lui a fait plus de 80
voient donc ça montre que voilà on
rassemble et c'est vraiment de volonté
de rassembler de rassembler encore plus
largement accord et je pense que
l'entrée de marc fesneau c'est aussi ça
alors justement vous l'évoquiez il ya eu
il ya un mois l'élection du nouveau
président de l'assemblée nationale donc
richard ferrand suite au départ de
françois de rugy au ministère de la
transition environnementale et à ce
moment là aussi à le député jean-louis
bourlanges qui déplorait je cite
l'inexistence politique du modèle à ce
moment là au mois de septembre
on est au mois de septembre et il ya eu
aussi cette épisode de françois bayrou
qui donne une interview au figaro
et qui dit que finalement emmanuel
macron tu devrais donner une ligne
directrice c'est ce qu'il a dit à ses
réformes
est ce que c'est un avis et c'est l'avis
que partage et plusieurs parlementaires
centristes
c'était le cas le modèle était
inexistant à ce moment là moi je
parlerais pas d une existence du tout on
voit l'assemblée les relations se passe
très bien et crépus le lendemain avec la
république en marche on est concertée en
amont des réformes inexistence pas du
tout puis on avait déjà geneviève
darrieussecq était secrétaire d'état et
jacqueline gourault qui était déjà
ministre auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur
c'est pas un petit ministère donc non il
n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas de manque
de considération qu'on a pu le lire jean
louis bourlanges est une personnalité
politique éminente qui a un franc parler
qui assez libre dans sa façon de voir
les choses mais nous on l'a pas vécu
comme ça
ce qui est important en revanche dans ce
remaniement là au delà de la question du
modem c'est l'élargissement aussi je
prends deux exemples franck riester qui
vient de la droite constructive de
progrès et didier guillaume qui était
l'ancien patron sous la mandature
présente des sénateurs au sénateur
socialiste bernois au sénat donc ça
montre qu'il ya encore cette volonté
d'élargir et et nous c'est aussi vers ça
qu'on essaie d'orienter le gouvernement
le premier ministre est présent la
république c'est de dire le cap et le
cap reste le même avec ce remaniement ne
change pas de cap ça c'est pas la
question mais c'est à dire que peut-être
il y avait deux trois choses qu'il
fallait améliorer
la partie la partie rassemblement
continuer à essayer de faire en sorte
que tous ceux qui se retrouvent dans le
projet mais qui en sont pas loin nous
rejoigne dans l' aventure et l'écoutent
l'écoutent d écoute des français et que
tes concitoyens et des territoires et
c'est pour ça que j'ai évoqué que ce
renforcement
ce renforcement de la place de la
question territoriale au sein du
gouvernement et quelque chose nous qui
nous que nous accueillons vraiment avec
avec bienveillance et à satisfaction
l'autre fait marquant cette semaine dans
l'actualité politique c'est les
perquisitions chez jean luc mélenchon et
dans les locaux de la france insoumise
des lieux perquisitionnés dans le cadre
de deux enquêtes préliminaires on le
voit à l'image sur les comptes de
campagne présidentielle et les
assistantes d'eurodéputés du parti quel
regard vous portez sur l'attitude
notamment de la france
insoumise face à ces opérations
judiciaires je vais pas vous mentir
moi je trouve ça assez désolant dans
l'attitude après je peux comprendre un
des perquisitions sait jamais un bon
moment c'est pas quelque chose de joyeux
on en a subit alors pour l'instant nous
il ya pas de suite c'était pareil aussi
une question de système parlementaire à
l'europe
ça semble quand même beaucoup plus
avancé du côté de la france a soumise
mais voilà moi j'ai pas vocation à
commenter des instructions pour qu'on va
laisser se dérouler ça et il ya aussi la
partie financement de campagne de jean
luc mélenchon qui poserait problème avec
supposément des problèmes de
surfacturation moi c'est son attitude
c'était jean luc mélenchon honnêtement
j'ai l'impression qu'on est en train de
le perdre et c'est pas la première fois
moi je me rappelle le lendemain
d'élection présidentielle il contestait
les résultats des élections
présidentielles il voulait refaire le
match
à chaque fois qu'ils leurs difficultés
j'ai l'impression qu'ils se trouvent ils
se trompent peas un peu c'est à dire
qu'il attaque les médias vous avez vu
comment il a parlé à l'une de votre
confrère en se moquant de son accent
pourtant il aime bien vous trouvez là
l'heure où on parle est en train de
faire une conférence de presse un peu
pour essayer de dire voilà c'est un coup
un coup politique c'est une police
politique qui est là pour pour essayer
de couler la france insoumise et mettre
des bâtons dans les roues à ce jeu
qu'est l'enjeu on sait très bien que ce
n'est pas le cas donc il a toujours un
discours un peu
un peu comme sa paradoxale c'est
vraiment désolant et il y à des
critiques ont là encore entendu
aujourd'hui les critiques au sein de son
propre camp qui commencent à se faire
entendre
moi je suis assez inquiet et franchement
je suis pas inquiet pour la france a
soumises ça c'est leur problème mais
pour le débat politique de voir des
personnalités politiques comme ça de
haut rang avoir un tel comportement ça
me ça me chagrine un peu alors dernière
thématique on va aborder ensemble c'est
si on revient dans les yvelines c'est la
fédération les républicains qui a un
nouveau président c'est pierre bédier
qui a été élu avec 58% des voix
votre regard sur cette reconstruction du
de la fédération les républicains dans
les yvelines
bon pas de réaction particulière parce
que c'est une élection interne à un
parti politique qui n'est pas le mien
donc pas vocation à commenter ni la
façon dont la campagne s'est tenu les
résultats des lions en tant que tel
après l'analyse politique que j'en fais
c'est que il ya une clarification de la
ligne politique de la droite yvelinoise
donc aujourd'hui la ligne officielle de
la droite silvinit noise celle de
monsieur bédié c'est celle de laurent
wauquiez
voilà donc c'est une droite qui dérive
de plus en plus vers la droite donc une
droite qui à mon avis est en tout cas
pour nous dans la majorité
arrivé à un stade de non retour ça va
être c'est impossible de s'entendre avec
aujourd'hui sont clairement dans
l'opposition et je pense qu on
l'évoquera peut-être un peu après voilà
après j'ai pas de leçon à donner en
termes de renouvellement mais c'est vrai
que pierre bédier ça fait un peu retour
vers le futur il a déjà digéré le
diriger la fédération des républiques à
118 ya un petit moment
après son score on nous avait annoncé
quand même un score important pour
pierre bédier
il fait 58 % ce qui veut dire qu'il ya
quand même une partie de la droite
évinoise qui se reconnaît pas ce soit
dans sa personnalité soit dans les idées
qu'ils portent et nous c'est peut-être à
cette droite là qu'on a envie de parler
cette droite peut-être un peu plus
modérées un peu plus de progrès alors je
dis pas que madame du blanc chez
quelqu'un qui est sur les mêmes idées qu
alain juppé mais alain juppé voilà les
gens savent comment il se situe
politiquement nous c'est vraiment à ses
militants et ses élus de droite là qu'on
veut parler notamment à l'approché des
européennes où je pense qu'il faut
vraiment qu'on arrive unis et si si on
arrive à monter quelque chose ensemble
je pense que l'europe arrivé ans on
arriverait à en sortir grandi
jean baptiste à monique merci d'être
venu sur notre plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes délégué départemental du modem
des yvelines
bah c'est un excellent week-end chez
nous on passe tout de suite au résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs jours déjà le hashtag
balances ton maire a fait son apparition
sur les réseaux sociaux des tweets pour
dénoncer les 6000 communes qui ont
augmenté leur taux de taxe d'habitation
en début de semaine nous avons reçu le
maire du chesnay philippe brillault où
le taux a été revu à la hausse d'environ
10%
écoutez le d'abord c'est pas un choix
c'est une contrainte
en fait si 10 % correspondent à
l'équivalent de 1 million 3 de recettes
sachant que le déficit en montant de
budgéter 2009 comprenant considérer que
la ville allait faire des économies pour
1 millions 6 et le million 3 bat serais
je dirais apportées par les habitants ça
représente à peu près 60 euros par foyer
et par an sachant que quelque part la
moyenne de la taxe d'habitation déchaîné
jien est de 670 euros était de 6 ans on
dit elle sera un petit peu plus de 700
pourquoi tout simplement parce que on a
eu une contravention une pénalité d'amis
lyon iii brutalement 2018
parce que nous n'avions pas nos 25 % de
logements sociaux comme un grand nombre
de communes le cinéma cyrano de
versailles fait peau neuve
ugc a décidé de réhabiliter cette salle
historique pour relancer sa
fréquentation
les premiers travaux débuteront en 2019
la société des cinémas de l'ouest
associations de marie-laure couderc et
du gc a obtenu l'autorisation de
l'agrandir cette salle les explications
sur ces travaux avec le reportage de
patrick jacques de dixmude et de manon
varaldo
à l'image des beatles edith piaf charles
aznavour johnny hallyday nombreux sont
ceux à s'être produit pour la première
fois en france sur la scène du cirano
mais le cinéma a perdu de nombreux
spectateurs des entrées pratiquement
divisé par deux depuis une vingtaine
d'années pour préserver ce lieu mythique
la ville de versailles travaillent en
collaboration avec ugc le but restaurer
entièrement la salle d' historique
c'est un projet très important pour nous
parce que c'est un cinéma au centre
ville et vous savez aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup la désertification des
centres-villes et pour nous depuis dix
ans que je suis maire c'est vraiment
avec mon équipe
un combat c'est soutenir à l'activité de
nos commerçants nos mille six cents
commerçants qui restent encore
centre-ville de versailles c'est une
reconstruction totale qui s'engage pour
le cirano il passera de 8 à 12 salles 10
seront accessibles pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite
un investissement important c'est un
investissement de l'ordre de 9 millions
d'euros
c'est donc un investissement stratégique
parce qu'il s'inscrit dans cette logique
de maillage et de proximité
nous pensons que aujourd'hui les gens
aux besoins d'accessibilité de proximité
et de lieux très qualitatif le cera ne
retrouvera son entrée historique celle
de l'époque des concerts après les
travaux l'accès se fera de nouveau par
la rue rameau on aime cette idée de
cinéma de quartier parce que c'est son
os et son identité
moi ce que j'aime c'est quand on a des
parents qui viennent avec leurs enfants
avec les parents disent aussi mon cinéma
c'est là où je viens viens depuis je
suis tout petit quand j'ai des
réalisateurs comme eric toledano comme
guillaume canet qui me disent ciné
cinéma je viens là depuis je suis tout
petit l'ouverture au public du nouveau
cyrano est prévue pour fin 2020 à la
recherche de leurs futurs employés c'est
l'objectif des sept enseignes du centre
commercial présente lors du forum de
l'emploi à l'espace saint quentin un
événement organisé par pôle emploi la
cité des métiers et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la possibilité
pour des recherches heures d'emploi de
trouver un poste
regardez ce reportage on recherche aussi
devenir vendeur conseil dans cette
enseigne de l'espace saint quentin 2
emplois recherchés par la responsable du
magasin nathalie leber un cdd pour la
période de noël est un cdi à partir du 4
novembre
c'est un vendeur mais vendeur conseil
mais on fait de la mise en rayon mais on
fait aussi du l'accompagnement client
terre où c'est à dire la personne et
remonte dans la boutique on l'accompagné
jusqu'à la fin de sa vente
c'est vraiment intéressant de pouvoir
voir directement les managers dans des
magasins et la rentrée dans notre
motivation vendeurs server manager ou
employés de rayons les différents postes
à pourvoir lors de ce forum organisé ce
jeudi 18 octobre au coeur de l'espace
saint quentin au total près de 25
emplois recherchés par cette enseigne du
centre commercial un événement organisé
par pôle emploi saint quentin en
yvelines le centre commercial et la cité
des métiers
l'objectif pour la cité des métiers
c'est de bien sûr de participer à la vie
économique du territoire
au temps du coup enfin pour les les
enseignes qui ont des besoins en
recrutement que pour les demandeurs
d'emploi où toutes les personnes
salariées étudiants qui rechercherait un
emploi dans ces domaines
l'idée effectivement du montage de ce
forum est le choix de la date correspond
à un calendrier pour les anciennes
l'idée c'est que les enseignes puisse
avoir un vivier disponible pour les
fêtes de fin d'année bien plus qu'un cv
ce sont les compétences qui sont mises
en avant les compétences et candidats et
la transférabilité de ses compétences
sur différents postes
on est sur les savoirs et des savoir
être et les savoir faire
près de 200 personnes sont venues sur le
forum pour déposer leur candidature un
problème lié à la circulation à nîmes
les maires de magny les hameaux bertrand
guillon et de voisins-le-bretonneux
alexandra aux eti la mère vit sinoise
propose une voie de contournement censé
désengorger sa commune aux heures de
pointe un contournement qui aurait des
conséquences sur magny les hameaux les
détails avec manon varaldo voisins le
bretonneux se situe au carrefour des
axes routiers qui relie la vallée de
chevreuse à versailles et saint quentin
en yvelines le développement du plateau
de saclay fait que chaque jour cette
circulation augmente dans la commune
pour mettre fin aux embouteillages et la
mère de voisins-le-bretonneux propose
une solution créer une voie de
contournement passant par magny les
hameaux afin de soulager la circulation
sur la d 36 où on s'est dit
ça arrange ça peut arranger ses
habitants aussi c'est à dire ça peut
leur éviter aussi des bouchons des
embouteillages mais il ya vraiment la
question environnementale qui est très
prégnante et que qui n'est pas
contournable à ce jour alors est ce que
quand la ligne 18 va arriver est ce que
ça peu cette nature à débloquer des
choses ou a poussé l'état à nous aider
dans d'autres solutions aujourd'hui j'ai
pas la réponse une idée communiqué dans
le journal municipal de septembre sans
en avertir le maire de magny les hameaux
j'étais surpris de cette proposition
mais surtout le lendemain je me suis
aperçu en lisant le magazine municipal
de voisins-le-bretonneux que cette
solution elle avait déjà été disputées
largement en amont avec le département
avec le député également ce que j'ai
trouvé particulièrement irrespectueux
dans le cadre des relations
intercommunales qu'on peut avoir
et puis je considère que c'est pas comme
ça qu'on travaille
la proposition implique de construire un
viaduc en pleine zone forestière classée
natura 2000 et d'ouvrir une nouvelle
voie de circulation au travers du parc
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
une conférence de presse commune inédite
a été organisée entre les groupes
d'opposition de voisins-le-bretonneux il
demande d'être associés au travail de la
ville sur la circulation
nous arrivons à un moment important de
la vie de notre vie nous avons un projet
à la remis 500 logements et nous avons
un carrefour qui est inadaptée nous
avons pas le début d'un projet
concernant ce carrefour vous avez la rue
de la mérantaise où mille véhicules
circulent entre 7h30 et 8h30
que faisons nous il est temps d'agir et
c'est ce que nous disons à jurançon pour
voisin les deux maires partage toutefois
le même objectif désengorger les routes
des voitures qui traversent en nombre
leurs communes passons tout de suite à
notre rubrique l'actualité en ile de
france
[Musique]
paris polluer mais paris réfléchit à des
solutions et notamment la gratuité des
transports publics l'objet d'un rapport
commandé par la mairie parisienne et
déjà quelques conclusions sur le sujet
un reportage de nos confrères de via
grand paris pour lutter contre la
pollution de l'air à paris
doit-on rendre les transports gratuits
pour répondre à cette question
la mairie de paris a commandé un rapport
la première partie a été dévoilé
première difficulté le financement pour
compenser les recettes versées par les
usagers l'opération coûtera au minimum 3
milliards d'euros par an reste à savoir
qui réglera la facture
les entreprises pourraient être
davantage sollicité aujourd'hui elles
financent 5 milliards par an soit 50 %
des coûts avec la révolution des
mobilités que nous allons connaître le
système de tarification tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui ne pourra plus fonctionner
et de voir comment est ce que l'on
pourrait avoir un système de
tarification incluant un certain degré
de gratuité et permettant d'avoir
quelque chose à la fois de plus
équitable et de plus orienté vers
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique est une approche écologique
de transport deuxième obstacle les
effets sur la qualité de l'air rien ne
prouve aujourd'hui que cette mesure
viserait les rues de paris de leur
véhicule dans son contre rapport la
région prévoit une réduction du trafic
automobile de 2%
le report modal se ferait sur les autres
types de mobilité comme le vélo ou la
trottinette
troisième point la fréquentation des
transports dans les villes où la
gratuité des transports s'applique
la fréquentation a augmenté qu'en
serait-il à paris où certaines lignes de
métro sont déjà saturées on partage le
fait que ce qui peut amener les gens
vers les transports en commun c'est
avant tout une amélioration de la
qualité service un développement de
l'offre pour régler les problèmes de
saturation et évidemment les problèmes
de retards qui sont tout de même
beaucoup trop fréquent
le rapport final des trois adjoints fin
décembre devrait apporter plus de
réponse aujourd'hui en france une
trentaine de villes ont choisi de rendre
leur transport gratuit depuis le 7
octobre les animaux ont pris la
possession de la salle patenôtre à
rambouillet près d'une centaine de
sculptures de différentes espèces
animales des créations de 43 artistes
originaires de toute la france
une exposition que vous pouvez découvrir
jusqu'au dimanche 21 octobre écouter
christian gehrig président de
l'association rambouillet arrêt partage
au micro de mélanie poké rambouillet
situé dans au milieu d'une forêt dans
lequel on a beaucoup d'animaux il ya une
tradition animalière à rambouillet
depuis fort longtemps et c'est cette
tradition là que nous avons souhaité
conserver
avec cette exposition liée aux animaux
en particulier
vous pouvez voir dans cette exposition
actuellement qu'il ya une très très
grande diversité dans les thèmes et qui
a pas seulement les animaux de la forêt
et il ya aussi beaucoup d'autres types
d'animaux avec d'ailleurs des techniques
complètement différentes les unes des
autres et c'est ça qui est un peu
surprenant dans cette exposition donc
c'est les artistes sont libres de
présenter leurs oeuvres animalière et
sans contrainte et terminons la semaine
avec en douceur avec ses images de bébés
panthères de chine ont vu le jour
récemment au zoo de thoiry now lee est
venu au monde en juillet dernier il est
visible par le public
yuki est né lui il ya quinze jours il
devra attendre avant de rejoindre son
grand frère dans le zoo
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de nous
avoir suivis vous pouvez revoir cette
émission en replay sur l'application
mobile ou sur notre site internet
retour de l'information lundi à partir
de 18h10 il a passé un excellent week
end
[Musique]